it's seven o'clock this is Sky News
breakfast our top stories this morning
two arrests have been made a man and a
woman following the fatal shooting of 26
year old Ellie Edwards in merseyside on
Christmas Eve
I'm here in the world where despite the
arrests police have renewed their appeal
for information following the shootings
spending at the sales as people head out
looking for bargains
I'm here on Oxford Street where the
number of Shoppers has been booming for
boxing Dale but not quite pre-pandemic
levels
at least 59 people are now known to have
died in a winter storm spreading across
the U.S and Canada
eases more covert measures no more
quarantine for foreign Travelers
arriving from next month
[Music]
China and concerns that the cost of
living crisis is stopping children going
to the theater or panto
sport Arsenal come back against West Ham
to win and go seven points clear at the
top of the Premier League
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at this morning's papers again with
writer and academic Mo Lovett and
broadcaster Pete price
[Music]
a very good morning thank you for
joining us welcome to Sky News breakfast
now police on merseyside have arrested a
30 year old man on suspicion of the
murder of Ellie Edwards Ellie who is 26
years old was shot dead while drinking
while enjoying a drink with her sister
and friends on Christmas Eve a 28 year
old man injured in the incident remains
in a critical condition a 19 year old
woman has also been arrested on
suspicion of conspiracy to murder Skies
into man Rasheed has the latest
developments from Wallace
Ellie Edwards was doing nothing but
enjoying herself on a night out she was
with her sister as they celebrated
bringing in Christmas together
but it was her who was caught in a line
of Reckless gunfire and murdered she's
just a gorgeous Soul isn't she yeah with
her that night were Jess and Meg like so
many friends for a girl much loved the
loss is immense we went to go and get a
drink went to the bar and then we just
did I just heard
people we thought it was fine
automatically everyone just stopped and
we were like
something's not right when they returned
Ellie had been shot in the head and
panic ensued she was going home to go to
sleep and wake up on Christmas with her
family it could have been anyone that
night it could it could have been anyone
and where we're very lucky but it
shouldn't have been alive it was only 10
minutes before Christmas Day when the
attack took place
[Applause]
in this CCTV we've obtained at least 12
gunshots can be heard
like just moments later those who were
celebrating on Christmas Eve are seen
leaving shocked confused and distraught
and within minutes of receiving a call
Emergency Services arrived but by then
police believe the gunman driving a dark
Mercedes had fled
on Monday evening a flurry of police
action led to two arrests first a 30
year old man on suspicion of murder and
attempted murder and a 19 year old woman
in custody on suspicion of conspiracy to
murder
the police are clear they will not rest
until they find those responsible for
Ellie's murder and the injuries
sustained by four others as they
question suspects in custody there will
be a sense of relief for many who are
adamant this kind of violence is unusual
for this area
it hasn't ever really
um manifested itself across the river on
the world in the way that we've seen
these kinds of Heartless attacks and and
and behavior of serious organized crime
going on over the other side of the
river and and so I think that that is
also a very worrying development at the
scene at least family including her dad
came to lay flowers for a person they so
deeply loved the last few days was
supposed to be some of the happiest
instead they've undoubtedly been the
worst
this was a woman snatched in the prime
of her life Ellie Edwards wasn't the
intended target she was an innocent
victim caught up in this brutal incident
into man Rasheed Sky News the Wirral
well joining us now from wallacy on the
world is Skies Becky Cottrell a very
good morning to you Becky certainly a
significant development overnight with
these arrests but many questions remain
and police continue to appeal for
information
yeah certainly questions remain and yes
these arrests will be a relief for the
moment for Ellie Edwards family and for
this community but as we've said the
police do not believe she was the
intended target of the attack so how did
she come to be caught up in this uh that
shooting on Christmas Eve at this Pub
just behind me uh police despite the
fact they are now questioning those two
suspects are still appealing for
information they are particularly Keen
to obtain any mobile phone or CCTV or
dash cam footage from that evening they
have said that they believe the gunman
uh fired into the front entrance of the
pub and then a short time after a dark
vehicle possibly an A-Class Mercedes was
seen leaving the pub car park so they
are still Keen to work out the timeline
of that evening that's surrounded
obviously this awful shooting as you
heard in Indy's report then we have
spoken to two friends of eddies who are
out with her that evening they said they
thought the gunshot initially were
fireworks and they spoke of their guilt
almost that they're still alive they're
relief but also their guilt that they
were able to celebrate Christmas with
their families in Ellie Edwards of
course was not they said that that
evening her sister had been asked and
that the two of them were particularly
closer and in a tribute to her sister
she said this is Lucy Ellie's sister she
said but Ellie was her bestest friend
and like a second mummy to her and we
saw her and the rest of Ellie's family
gather here yesterday to lay flowers in
tribute to Ellie Edwards there were lots
of colorful bouquets with cards with
personal messages to Ellie and about
Ellie and photos of Ellie and it was as
you can imagine an incredibly somber
moment her father in particular looked
as you would expect very emotional and
this is a time when normally her family
would be coming together to celebrate
Christmas and the holidays and they are
instead having to deal with this huge
horrendous blow and the loss of Eli
Edward's life
okay Becky for now thank you Becky
cotton across those developments for us
uh in merseyside we'll bring you more to
that more on that throughout the program
now Shoppers across the UK have defied
Boxing Day predictions as football
bounced back from 2021 in contrast to
what many were expecting the number of
Boxing Day Shoppers across the UK
increased by 50 percent compared to last
year despite rail strikes football in
central London was up sharply by 139
percent compared to last year but the
numbers still fell short of pre-pandemic
levels across the UK they were down by
almost a third compared to 2019.
of course guys Savage Chowdhury joins us
now from Oxford Street in central London
very good morning to you Saba certainly
a little surprise that uh football is up
on last year but still nowhere near the
level it normally is
good morning absolutely retailers were
preparing for a quiet Boxing Day some uh
major stores even start seeing their
sales a week before going up to 80 that
doesn't usually happen and that is of
course because of concerns around the
cost of living crisis and the rail
strikes they genuinely thought that less
people will be coming out to shop so I
think it's safe to say that they were
pleasantly surprised when they received
the data from the analysts springboard
now springboard a measure the footfall
which is essentially the number of
people that come to a shop or to a
shopping center during a particular
juncture and the data now that we have
is up to midday yesterday now this is
where it gets interesting the number of
people going shopping compared to last
year has more than doubled and we're
talking over 50 now that is significant
considering the economic hardships this
country has been facing in recent months
or even recent years I should say with
the pandemic so it was a welcome news to
many of the retailers and many on this
High Street so encouraging data because
it shows people are spending however it
must be said that this data while it is
high compared to last year when we
compare it to pre-pandemic levels it's
still under by around 30 so an important
caveat there and also the fact that this
data does not include uh online uh
spending as well now in the next hour
few hours we will have for you even more
up-to-date data which will show us what
spending like was like across the day uh
during the Boxing Day sales
thank you
let's have a look at some of the other
news this morning and opposition to new
housing developments could be reduced if
there was a greater focus on design and
the Heart and Soul of places that's
according to the leveling up secretary
Michael Gove he's hit out at what he's
called indifferent or insipid planning
saying some good housing developments
are let down by poor Landscaping
the boss of hs2 has hailed the Project's
immense progress in 2022 chief executive
Mark Thurston said a series of
Milestones were reached over the past 12
months however it's feared stage one of
Europe's biggest infrastructure project
could go way over its 40 billion pound
budget
at least 59 people are now known to have
died across North America as the U.S and
Canada continue to be battered by
ferocious winter storms some were found
dead in their cars in snow drifts NBC
News corresponded Emily Ikeda sent us
this report from New York City
while the City of Buffalo buried and
unrecognizable as the death toll from
the devastating Deluge of heavy winds
and heavy snow continues to rise
officials reporting 27 deaths so far in
Erie County New York alone some victims
found in snow Banks and cars after this
blistering blizzard brought even First
Responders efforts at some points to a
complete standstill of victims
apparently dying from exposure according
to officials others lack of heat and
cardiac events after shoveling snow
officials say between today and tomorrow
parts of Buffalo could see up to another
foot of snow hampering ongoing urgent
search and rescue missions happening on
the ground in the region there 400
National Guardsmen on the ground
fortunately we're hearing that
conditions should improve in the coming
days with warming temperatures on the
way but the sweeping Storm's timing it
certainly brought a lot to a standstill
and we continue to see the link
lingering impacts on travel more than
fourteen thousand flight cancellations
since Friday Southwest Airlines mixing
more than 60 percent of its flights the
airline apologizing to customers in a
statement calling its challenges
unacceptable and promising to urgently
reposition Crews keep in mind flight
disruptions to this degree can take days
to work out
Emily I cater there in New York for us
with that update meanwhile here the Met
Office has issued a yellow weather
warning for the north of England and
across Scotland too travel disruption is
expected and traffic Scotland is urging
people to plan ahead before traveling
with ice and snow already on several of
the major roads
to China now where they've announced it
will drop a covid-19 quarantine
requirement for passengers arriving from
overseas in the latest easing of the
country's strict measures to control the
spread of the virus Skies Helena Smith
has the latest from Beijing
this latest news today that these final
few restrictions that existed are being
dropped is really a strong indication
that there is now no going back for
China zero covert absolutely feels like
it is a thing of a past death thing of
the past it would simply be too late now
to try and rein in the virus that is
spreading frankly like wildfire through
this country so those last some of the
last remaining restrictions that are
being dropped International Travelers
coming into the country will no longer
have to be quarantined in in hotels at
various times during this epidemic that
quarantine has been as long as three
weeks currently it's five days in a
hotel plus three days at home that will
no longer be necessary the disease and
the handling of it is also going to be
downgraded and it had been graded as a
category handling we're saying the
disease itself would have been category
B but the handling of it was category a
which essentially gave the government
the power to quarantine people in their
homes and whatnot that is being
downgraded essentially meaning that uh
responsibility for handling the disease
prevention and response is now back in
the hands of the doctors rather than the
government and finally testing will no
longer be mandatory so up until now
people have had to get a test in this
country almost every couple of days you
know for a year or so so it is really
really dramatic changes remember it is
actually fewer than three weeks ago that
the government undertook this dramatic
U-turn away from zero covert and I can't
over emphasize enough just how
dominating zero covered was in the lives
of people here you had to get tested all
the time you couldn't enter any public
place or building or Park without a code
on your phone showing that you were
negative if you were infected you would
be taken away to a quarantine facility
at a moment's notice you could be locked
down in your home whole cities of
millions of people would be locked down
entirely over a handful of cases and
it's gone from all of that really to
almost nothing in the space of about
three weeks the net results sadly is
that there are many many any infections
and probably many deaths we really just
don't know how many because the numbers
simply aren't being reported there was
only one death reported in Beijing
yesterday for example but anecdotally
many hundreds possibly many a thousands
of people are dying because this is an
enormous population with relatively low
levels of immunity because that virus
hadn't been spreading and actually
although vaccination amongst young
people is not too bad that full
vaccination including boosters amongst
the elderly is actually reasonably low
so there is anecdotal evidence that
hospitals like like the one behind me
and others and crematoriums some are
becoming overwhelmed but just the degree
to that which that's happening is very
very difficult to ascertain but truly a
dramatic turnaround in this Flagship
policy within China
Helen Ann Smith with the latest there
from China now trained services will
continue to be disrupted today with the
latest 48-hour strike by the rmt union
finishing at just six o'clock this
morning another Union the tssa has now
begun a 24-hour strike hitting
cross-country trains Network rail are
warning passengers to prepare for
significant disruption into the new year
with national strikes planned on the
third and fourth and the sixth and 7th
of January well joining me now is the
travel editor of the independent Simon
Calder who's at Paddington Station uh
hello to you Simon thanks for joining us
Merry Christmas
yes um Merry Christmas to you but sadly
not for rail passengers um the first
trains out of here won't be going for
another couple of hours I'm sorry to say
oh
artist strike ended around an hour and a
quarter ago just how much disruption did
it cause to Christmas travel and how
long is it going to take for normal
services to resume
really good questions when the rmt
called this strike it was a kind of
bonus strike this one was aimed squarely
at Network Rail and the union said we
just want to disrupt the 120 million
pounds worth of engineering Works taking
place over Christmas day and boxing day
so it started at 6 p.m on Christmas Eve
as you say finished an hour and 20
minutes or so ago but it actually had a
much more dramatic effect which is why
you had extraordinary things on Sunday
on uh Christmas Eve people having to
leave pantomimes halfway through to
catch the last trains pretty much
everything had finished by about four
o'clock in the afternoon reaching its
destination total shutdown and I was
looking forward to the first train being
in uh at 7 53 this morning from
Sheffield to Plymouth that's now being
canceled so if you're watching in
Edinburgh you can be the first
passengers to travel by train since
Christmas the 759 from there to Glasgow
Queens Street one minute later there's a
train from Glasgow Queen Street back to
Edinburgh Waverly and then one minute
past eight first Euro star train from
London to Paris that was uh the entire
service yesterday 43 International
trains wiped out as a result of this
strike and then well Manchester Airport
gets its first service departing
Manchester Piccadilly at five past eight
but that's a bus Replacement Service
because of course we're now well into
the festive engineering works so a
miserable time for travelers and as you
say Well Network rail at Houston Station
are saying to anybody who's involved in
the west coast Mainline don't even think
about traveling unless you absolutely
have to until the 9th of January
now Simon is always a bit of travel
chaos at this time of year how much
worse has it been with this strike
action that we've seen on the railways
also border force uh at airports as well
you know impacting arriving passengers
passport control what is the impact of
that have that been on on other forms of
travel like Aaron Road
well in terms of Aviation we were all
there um Sky News was there on Friday
morning 23rd of December busiest day at
many of the Nations airports uh this
winter
expecting to see because we've been
warned of
um some significant disruption both by
the government and by Airlines and and
there wasn't any basically um every
airport and though that was Heathrow
Gatwick Manchester Birmingham Glasgow
and Cardiff they all cooked absolutely
fine
um there's not a strike today they
resume tomorrow at members of the PCS
Union working for UK border force in a
dispute overpay
um but even when that does come back I
think that uh we're not going to see any
significant disruption there the big
problem is across the Atlantic of course
as you've been reporting
um extreme weather in the northeastern
United States and in Canada we're seeing
quite a lot of delays coming in and I
tell you what anybody if I had a
connecting flight from the UK to
somewhere in that region with an onward
flight
um I would be thinking very carefully
about that because we are seeing
cancellations by the thousands of
flights within the U.S and in particular
Southwest Airlines has canceled more
than half of its schedule it's an
absolute mess there
absolutely and they are of course
expecting even more uh snowfalls Simon
now looking ahead into the new year
these rail strikes are going to continue
what inside knowledge do you have if any
about how these talks are going are we
any closer to a resolution there are no
talks that was the slightly plaintive
message on Friday from the um rmt Union
they put out something saying ministers
have gone missing we want to talk and
certainly when I talk to individual
Railway men and women you know they have
lost um hundreds of pounds sometimes
thousands of pounds in the so far 16
days of strikes that the rmt has called
nationally
um by the way we've got another as left
train drivers strike sort of slotted in
on the 5th of January to make the first
week back at the return to work
um pretty impossible for everyone
um so I sense that we will be moving
towards a a conclusion probably around
about out the second week once the next
set of strikes is finished we should get
uh talks resuming but frankly every
single day that this goes on it cheeses
off the passengers many of whom are now
going to be looking for other options to
travel and it especially cheeses off the
taxpayer many of whom never go near a uh
a train and yet are being told yes
you've got to pump yet more but billions
into the railway even though this very
Railway is telling people not to try to
travel because things are in such a mess
it's um
desperate State of Affairs and we
haven't really seen anything this bad
for for a generation I'm afraid yeah
certainly has felt like an extraordinary
Christmas period for travel Simon we
appreciate your thoughts thanks so much
thank you a very good morning you're
watching Sky News breakfast our top
stories
two arrests have been made a man and a
woman following a fatal shooting of 26
year old Ellie Edwards in merseyside on
Christmas Eve
at least 59 people are now known to have
died in the winter storm spreading
across the U.S and Canada
China is te's more covered measures
there'll be no more quarantine for
foreign Travelers arriving from next
month
now last week's Sky News spoke with
Carol Morrison a woman who was
Sheltering in a warm bank because she
couldn't afford her heating now after
seeing our report ten-year-old Nathan
caligbo from Ireland offered to donate
his pocket money to Carol he'd been
having a sleepless night worrying about
her well-being well Sky's Aisha zaheed
has brought Carol and Nathan together to
hear their stories
for Carol keeping her home warm this
winter has been difficult she's had to
rely on a warm bank at her local
community library that's where we first
met and when I'm here it's like
everything disappears
I don't have to worry about anything
I forgot until five of them here it's
lovely and then when I go home I know
it's bedtime
because then I have to take my my
medication tonight
then I go to bed because what else is
there it's going to be freezing though
miles away in Ireland 10 year old Nathan
had been watching our report with his
mother lavender he was moved to tears
and eager to help so Nathan are you
excited about meeting I'm very very
excited I'm I'm overjoyed and now the
Kellogg balls and Carol finally catch up
hi Carol Hi how are you I'm good
actually I'm much better today yeah so
tell me how
you were worried for me what had
happened was Ireland just had this whole
one week of ice
and it was like biting cold and he was
sick
so he had just gone through the whole
dose of steroids and all that because of
the cold so what just came to his mind
was like what could happen to this lady
I was worried for you because I saw you
that in the cold if you were like that I
don't know what could have happened so I
really wanted to donate to help you to
get out of the cold and also to be able
to have a warm house
I don't really want to take your savings
I don't think I would that would sit
comfortably with me but I really am
appreciated
of of your kind thoughts
for me I think you've helped me
emotionally that you've really touched
my heart you really have you've touched
my heart
I could be more happier now
I feel like I've got an adopted son
we should definitely keep in touch yes
no problem no problem give me a smile
give me a smile Nate that's better you
look pretty when you have a smile
yeah a smile is a very good thing to
have
and don't lose it okay
and don't worry about me don't worry
about me I'll be okay they may be
Generations apart but one thing's for
certain Nathan's kind gesture has left
more of an impact than he could have
ever imagined I shazid Sky News
what a thoughtful little boy that's
certainly my favorite story of the
morning now have tampan has got it all
wrong according to a report today good
housing plans can be ruined because they
don't fit in with a local landscape and
that is why lots of people simply don't
like them a new report by policy
exchange today suggests that many of the
plans are mediocre well joining me now
is ik EJ head of housing architecture
and urban space in policy exchange a
very good morning to you Ike forgive me
I think I mispronounced your name there
Merry Christmas thanks for joining us
morning no problem Merry Christmas now
tell us what you've learned uh carrying
out this research what are you proposing
is needed when it comes to town planning
and and what changes could make the
biggest differences
well essentially we're proposing a new
school of place a national school of
place that will be responsible for
um dispense and the very best standards
of architecture town planning design to
new generation of built environment
professionals to enable them to go out
and basically create better more
beautiful and more sustainable places
and obviously we have existing
architecture schools and planning
schools but our idea is to really
re-galvanize the idea of beauty
sustainability making sure that we get
places right which prevents which
presents a whole world of them a whole
host of kind of urban benefits but
chiefly within a political context we
genuinely believe it may also help solve
the housing crisis
truth is though uh we're all nimbies at
heart aren't we no one wants new
Construction and building work going on
in their backyard how do you get around
this well basically
nimbyism can be profoundly annoying
nobody denies that but look any anybody
who believes in living in a democracy
and Free Will has to go along with the
fact that Nimbus have to exist so my our
solution as represented in the report to
nimbyism is not to demonize nimbies but
it's to basically remove some of the
elements that make them nimbies in the
first place and one of those elements is
not the only element and it won't get
rid of nimbleism overnight but one of
those elements is poor design a fear of
poor design a fear of their communities
homes and neighborhoods will be blighted
by other developments that simply aren't
good enough quality so if we can make
sure that the quality increases then
that will eventually hopefully help
increase public confidence in the
quality of new design which would be one
of the ways in which nimbyism can be
addressed
now Secretary of State for leveling up
Michael Gove is backing your plan what
difference could planning make in terms
of improving equality
well essentially the planning system is
the custodian of our built environment
um everything has to go through the
planet system you have to get planning
permission in order to build it's
basically that simple so I'm not I mean
there are many structural flaws within
the planning system we're not staying a
new school of a place we'll solve all of
them but it will hopefully enable the
planning system to be able to more
readily identify what is good and what
is positive and also help pursue it as
well and this also we this we hope
eventually will have this trickle-down
effect of essentially making the places
we all live better and as we say our
kind of long-term plan for that it won't
happen overnight is by that increase in
public confidence in the quality of
Housing and design that can help reduce
the opposition new housing often gets
which will enable more housing to be
built which could enable the housing
crisis to be
um resolved okay so paint the picture
for us if you can Ike what changes are
you proposing uh that would create these
new urban areas and what what does that
perfect housing estate look like
well that's a good question
um in terms of a perfect housing estate
what we would say I mean Perfections
obviously um wouldn't necessarily say
anything is perfect but in terms of a
good quality Housing Development would
say I would need to do certain things
there would need to be character it
would need to have Urban character it
would need to have a sense of place
you'd have to go there and feel uplifted
and not necessarily feel depressed or
marginalized um in the way that some
housing developments can sometimes be it
would also when we envisage which would
have been delivered through public
consultation now public consultation
exists but it exists in a way in which
many people often feel kind of forced
out
um of the process and they don't have
their voices heard this new school as
well as promoting quality in design it
will also promote the idea of rigorously
we're not saying um Urban Development
should be done by a kind of a beauty
parade or public consent but just making
sure the public are more involved so
basically the idea of um Beauty the idea
of higher quality and the idea of a
greater influence for improvable
popularity
um public consultation democratizing the
process making people fall in making
people feel more enfranchised and
involved these are the things which we
eventually hope will percolate into the
system from a national school of place
in order to make the housing market
better and more representative of what
people may want as well okay fascinating
stuff like EJ uh great talking to you
thanks so much for joining us thank you
very much Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
time now for a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
after boxing day's cold and showery
theme the rest of the week looks milder
with spells of wind and rain it's a wet
and windy start in the west with snow
for Britain's Northern Hills but Eastern
parts are mainly fine there will be icy
stretches in places as well rain will
move across more of Britain during the
morning but Central and Southeast
England will stay largely fine there
will be further snow on Northern Hills
especially north of the central belt of
Scotland where disruption is possible
too so take care on the roads we'll have
more on that throughout the program
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News breakfast still
to come this morning we'll be taking a
look through this morning's papers with
writer and academic Mo Lovett and
broadcaster Pete price that's coming up
[Music]
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk
[Music]
online ski hire in Europe
the recent rain and Mild conditions
across the Alps have seen many valleys
turning green again I'm afraid it'll
become colder this week but there will
be very little snow in the forecast for
those venturing off peace in Western
Austria there is still a precarious
Avalanche situation in places France has
some of the best conditions at the
moment with the majority of ski lifts
running there
meanwhile artificial snow is still
covering some of the slopes in Italy I'm
afraid and finally Switzerland has good
snow altitude with nearly two meters
being reported at South Bay
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk online ski hire in Europe
now with us this morning to review the
papers a writer and academic Mo Lovett
and broadcaster Pete price hi to you
both again uh I think we're kicking off
with uh yumo aren't we you've pulled out
this story from the daily mail
um an interview that Theresa May gave to
uh radio 4. it was a fascinating
interview uh yesterday I should know if
you heard it but certainly she's
confident that Rishi sunat may be able
to close this enormous pole Gap with
labor
yeah well I thought we hadn't had very
much Party politics this morning so and
we'd focus in on this interview that you
as you say Theresa May gave yesterday
um she's claims that Rishi sunak is
rebuilding trust and that there is time
for the Tories to turn it around and win
the next general election now this is
against the backdrop that Paul's
suggesting labor party have a 20-point
lead at the moment and I've had a fairly
substantial lead for the last six months
as far as I I can remember
um and um Sir John Curtis our election
Guru that we all know and love
um has said Tory support is really
plummeted in the wake of kind of
unforced errors and also the economic
backdrop that we've been talking about
all morning and so I think it's an
interesting one I mean the thing
obviously is about rallying the troops
isn't it and I think the one thing I
always think about elections is that you
should never ever take the electorate
for granted
um you know no matter what the polls say
people will make their mind up on the
damage should never be taken for granted
but um what what I would hate is for
um for the parties to either kind of
admit defeat or to to kind of be
complacent about a win and for people
not to listen to the lectures I mean
that that's one of the things that I
think we've had sort of quite a slovenly
political class of late that aren't
really kind of tackling some of the
problems we face in society but although
this might be about rallying the troops
I do think it's good not to be
complacent about
um what the outcome of the next general
election might be and I love the in this
little piece in the meal the very last
paragraph it says Nadine Doris has
suggested it if the Tory numbers keep
slipping Boris Johnson will be back in
number 10. uh now that just made me
smile I let viewers make what they think
but I thought that was quite a funny
little final paragraph gosh more likely
to be back in number 10 or or in the
jungle who knows right uh he you pulled
out this story on the front page of the
Guardian which frankly I found quite
shocking when I was reading it this
morning uh that student homelessness is
rising uh it says here that not since
the 1970s have they seen anything like
this when students were sleeping in
sports halls and cars this is all very
depressing isn't it
it is depressing but I'm really
surprised at the story it says that the
purpose-built student accommodation is
uh not uh expanding the way it was now
if they came to Liverpool you've never
seen so much accommodation in your life
I've never seen high-rise blocks being
put up so fast and it's all a student
accommodation we're a big student City
anyway so I think that's really exciting
but on the private sector the landlords
are changing their mind and not using
students like they used to also the
rules and regulations are making it more
difficult but there's bigger problem a
bigger problem for these people these
lovely students are bringing so much
money into our cities is they're getting
uh
substantial bills for their electricity
on top of their rents and they are
struggling to keep warm and to keep and
they've got to be warm when they're
doing their work but they're having big
problems but I'm surprised that they're
saying that this problem is the biggest
problem since 1970 it it doesn't make
sense to me because Liverpool is
absolutely packed packed with a student
accommodation
isn't it but it's whether they can
afford it I suppose isn't it um they
can't afford it that's a sad thing but
you see a couple of my friends I'm gonna
get castigated for this a couple of my
friends kids our students but they've
got part-time jobs as well because they
want to make it work
yeah well uh certainly I always had a
job when I was at University
um and it's certainly that a lot of
students do have to do isn't it um Mo to
this story that you've pulled out from
the times today saying that stay at home
fathers are up 34 since the pandemic one
in nine uh full-time parents are now men
it's interesting yeah I mean yeah it is
interesting I think it's one of those
things that you know pandemics change
societies don't they they change
attitudes and uh this is one of those
stories or at least accelerate under
underlying Trends in society so um yeah
as you say um one in one in nine
full-time parents now so that's parents
who don't work but are full-time parents
um uh our our fathers now and that's
that's kind of compared to one in 14
back in 2019 whereas mothers um you know
full-time moms who don't work and that's
fallen from 1.3 million to 1.2 million
in the same period I mean the numbers
are sort of 140 000 compared to 1.2
million so you can see that you know
stay-at-home parenting is still the
majority uh women doing that I mean the
report it says uh itself says that this
is um you know this is due to it's a
good thing for
um equity and pay because it means that
women are able to go out and earn more
and I think it's interesting because one
thing the report doesn't talk about is
what type of work and the kind of the
changes of work I mean we knew in the
pandemic that you know it was mostly the
middle class that could stay at home
with a computer-based job whereas uh
manual workers had to go out and be in
society so so that's a different kind of
quality of work whether you you you're
out and using manual labor and you're or
you're behind a computer and so it
doesn't really cut across whether or not
it has affected uh pay and conditions
for women in the workplace but I just
think it's a very interesting site kind
of sign of the times in the way
attitudes are changing I mean there's
one father who said if he hadn't worked
from home during the pandemic if he'd
been in the office it may never have
occurred to him that he could be a
stay-at-home father and then he's taken
that decision so yeah as he said quite
interesting yeah very interesting
certainly a lot of um fathers who used
to travel a lot for work really enjoyed
that time at home uh seeing their
children grow up during the pandemic
certainly that's eye-opening for a lot
of people wasn't it um now this story
that you've pulled out from the eye pete
uh covid restrictions coming back to
Care Homes this is all quite sad isn't
it it's it is absolutely incensed to me
this story it's not just Kobe it's the
flu uh it's vomiting bugs they're
talking about shutting down for visitors
when we had the pandemic well shut down
people died there were prisoners in
those I understand that the Care Homes
had to help them but they were prisoners
to do it again these people here in
their last part of their life they need
some sort of of relationship some sort
of contact with people they love and the
idea that Care Homes could close down
again through the winter I understand
the problems they've got but they've got
to work harder to keep these problems at
Bay because these people are prisoners
in their homes and they're dying and and
it was Dreadful in the pandemic so many
people didn't say goodbye to their loved
ones this is an awful story and it's got
to be addressed yeah it's certainly not
good news for so many families a quick
thought from you Mo before we go uh the
sun snow go for UK it was a white
Christmas official
officially we had a white Christmas
um and uh it used to be the case that if
a snowflake fell on the Met Office in
London on Christmas day it would be a
white uh White crisp but now in an era
of dumbing down it can be anywhere in
the UK and it can be any time within the
24 hours of Christmas day so yes
although it was too warm in England and
Wales there were Parts
we'll see you again the next hour thank
you so much and we'll have more on all
our top stories at the top of the hour
stay with us
[Music]